- Once I see that he's starting
to fall back a little bit,
and I see Rudy’s speed in the
background, you know, kinda speeding up,
I can tell that Rudy's
got the edge on him.
That's my cue to throw the lob.
What's up, guys?
This is Mike Conley,
and I'mma take you
through “The Breakdown”
—what makes me one of the best
point guards in the NBA.
I play more of a game that's
patient. It's reactive.
Whatever you give me,
I take advantage of.
The guy defending you, kind
of draped over you, just
getting them on your
hip a little bit
to where you control his
body a little bit more,
and you're in control
of the action.
It might look like
you're pressured,
and it feels like a
pressure situation,
but you're truly in
complete control.
You see Rudy there. He
doesn't set the screen.
He instead dives straight
down the gut as soon
as his man commits a
little bit into coverage.
I read it right away.
Like, as soon as I saw him,
that one, you kinda just—
you know you gonna
thread the needle.
He knows he's gonna catch it
and have a two-step to the rim,
either dunk or layup, and
it's on him to finish it.
These metrics have
helped me just
understand when I'm watching
the film now, just knowing
that these are situations
where, hey, they're all over me,
and we're still gonna
make this play.
How can we get myself
into a situation
where I can create a
little bit more space?
Get this guy off my back, not
have to be put into a situation
where I can potentially
make a mistake.
This one is a typical
one-two play for us.
For me and Rudy, it's what
we call a hip screen,
side pick-and-roll.
I always read the
guy guarding me,
what he's gonna
do, go over or under.
If he goes under, I shoot it.
If he goes over, I
then keep my dribble and
play my way into the paint.
Secondly, I look at the big
and if he's dropping back
or if he's pushing up.
Once I see that he's starting
to fall back a little bit,
and I see Rudy’s speed
in the background, you know, kinda
speeding up, I can tell that
Rudy's got the edge on him.
That's my cue to throw the lob.
When I get the ball,
I see that I have
the advantage on
the guy guarding me.
So, like, at that point, I
don't worry about the guy
who's guarding me.
Next is the guy who's helping
from the top of the key.
I see him kinda fake stunt to
try to, you know, get back to the shooter.
And at that point, my
eyes are either first
at that big that's
guarding Rudy,
seeing if he comes up or not.
Cuz if he does, I'm
throwing it immediately.
If he starts to fall back
a little bit, like, initially,
right at that free-throw
line point,
I automatically
look at the corner
to see if maybe that corner
guy's man has helped over.
Also, to help over
on the lob on Rudy.
If he doesn't move like
he does on this play,
I know that's just
a two-man game.
That's an almost impossible
play to stop.
Things you work on, you try
to work on, at a young age
is reading the defender
guarding a guy on a
pindown. In this case, it's Donovan.
They trail, and Donovan's
looking to curl that screen
and get downhill and put
himself in that position
where he forces the
big to make a decision.
In this case, the guard
shoots the gap of the screen,
and Donovan's anticipating
it, and so am I.
And as soon as he does,
Rudy being the screener
that he is, he's smart enough
to flip it really quickly,
catch a piece of him.
I'm able to throw
the ball to a spot.
I'm just throwing
it to an area where
I know that he's gonna kinda
get close to. Makes the catch,
and that's the teed-up
three for our best guy.
We just try to find an advantage
and play advantage basketball.
Some days we create what
we call the blender, where
the ball is just moving,
moving, moving.
We’re able to throw it around,
swing it, swing it, drive
it again, then swing it again.
By that time, the team
is kinda checked out,
and then somebody gets an open shot.
This whole three-point barrage
thing is new to me too.
I'm still learning
it. Everybody's
got this green light.
I've been in the league for so
long that when I first came in,
it was a lot of post-up play.
I mean, shoot, I played against Shaq.
We were all trying
to be a threat.
Five threats on the court,
it makes it extremely tough
and puts a lot of
pressure on defenses
to have to guard everybody.
When that happens, the
efficiency pops up.
It'll just happen organically.
Guys are turning down good
shots for great shots,
and it's contagious.
I think that's what makes us
special right now.
I appreciate you sitting
here watching my film session
on “The Breakdown.”
I gave you a little bit
of what I like to do
and how I read different
coverages in the
pick-and-roll, and hopefully you
learned something from it.
And hopefully I'll see you
guys on the court.
Thanks.